John C Reilly once said that he can't
leave his house without being asked
about his stepbrother sequel but fans
expecting more silly Shenanigans from
Brennan and Dale are going to be
disappointed here's why ever since
Brennan huff and Dale doback resolved
their differences fans of Step Brothers
have wanted to see more
did we become best friends yep the 2008
box office hit re-teamed Talladega night
Stars Will Ferrell and John C Reilly as
immature grown men who still mooch off
their appearance and nearly destroy
everyone's lives in the process while
everything ended happily Step Brothers
generated so many ridiculous scenes and
memorable lines that it's almost
inconceivable that a sequel never into
production and you're not gonna not get
Randy Jackson's autograph right I would
have done the exact same thing so why
didn't Farrell Riley and director Adam
McKay ever revisit Bryn and Dale in
their messy family Dynamic over the last
decade and a half well after the success
of Step Brothers a follow-up film was
actually in the works but as McKay told
collider Paramount Pictures asked him
and Farrell to make a different sequel
Anchorman 2. after filming that 2013
sequel McCay and Farrell decided they
didn't want to do another Step Brothers
anymore McKay explained to the outlet I
don't want to get into the sequel
business too much McKay wanted to try
new things and subsequently he built a
lane for himself as a filmmaker of
satirical comedies like Vice and don't
look up but Step Brothers 2 is even less
likely to happen now following a
professional and personal falling out
between McKay and Farrell that revolved
around their Step Brothers collaborator
John C Reilly in 2019 McKay and Farrell
announced that they had ended their
creative partnership and closed their
company Gary Sanchez Productions years
later the reasons behind the split are
urged as an executive producer McKay
helped bring winning time the rise of
the Lakers Dynasty the HBO in 2022
winning time Stars Riley as team owner
Jerry Buss although Pharaoh lobbied hard
for that role McKay gave it to Riley
without letting Farrell know McKay told
Vanity Fair I should have called him and
I didn't the director also went on to
say that he and Farrell no longer speak
to each other additionally both Riley
and Pharaoh have told reporters that his
sequel to Step Brothers is a highly
unlikely proposition in a 2018 interview
with screen Crush Riley explained that
he and Farrell as well as Adam McKay
would rather pursue new projects instead
of making a stepbrother sequel unless we
were really sure that we could do a
better version or improve on what it is
right let's leave it alone as for feral
he admits he's thought about a sequel
But ultimately decided against it the
actor told Rolling Stone in 2017. you
have to resist the temptation It's just
tough because the the things everyone
wants you to do sequels of are special
because there's not a sequel of it but
even though A Step Brothers 2 will
probably never get made Adam McKay said
that he and his collaborators have
already worked out a plot for a
potential sequel McKay told collider we
have a whole story an outline that we're
happy with although McKay didn't reveal
any more information about the plot Will
Ferrell shared the fleshed out premise
for Step Brothers 2 with the New York
daily news in 2017. as Farrell told the
outlet the sequel would have centered
around Brennan and Dale moving into a
retirement community with their aging
parents played by Richard Jenkins and
Mary steenbergen so if a Step Brothers 2
was to ever happen would the entire cast
return well seeing as the original film
is a buddy comedy it would be
Unthinkable to make a sequel without
either Pharaoh or Riley reprising their
roles furthermore while discussing
possible plot lines for a sequel both
Farrell and McKay mentioned significant
roles for Brennan and Dale's parents so
this means Mary steenbergen and Richard
Jenkins would need to return as Nancy
huff and Robert doback fortunately
steambergen told screen Crush that she'd
be happy to appear in a sequel the Oscar
winner told the outlet I would be there
day one with the biggest smile on my
face I love those guys and the joy of
working with them Step Brothers also
featured Adam Scott and Catherine Hahn
in supporting roles both actors would go
on to find greater levels of Fame on
shows like Parks and Recreation and one
division filmmakers would certainly want
their star power in Step Brothers too so
it's a good thing that Han is definitely
on board
foreign